hey horror movie fans my name is Ryan
right and I'm Jerry and I'm Alyssa Marie
we're three movie buffs
and we're going to give you reasons to
see and not to see a dad
this book after their friend needs to
kick their drug addiction five friends
head to a cabin in the woods where one
of them who looks like Gerry discovers
the Book of the Dead
decides to read from the book that
clearly states don't read it and
unleashes demons that set out to
brutally destroy them going to die
tonight reason to see number one brutal
terror it's pretty relentless this movie
is definitely brutal terror once he the
terror kicks in it becomes almost
non-stop it doesn't hold back it doesn't
give any crap about anything
it's uh it's a violent [ __ ] movie
is a great cross of like supernatural
terror and but there's a big sense of
realism at the same time so the terror
really [ __ ] hits hard
yeah and it's it's almost gleefully you
know horror yeah
it's a weird thing because no matter how
brutal it was every time terror was on
the screen that's when I noticed I was
subconsciously eating popcorn injury in
my soda I was the most excited during
those scenes
now this movies like the best roller
coaster I've been on in a while like oh
absolutely there yeah there's one
particular scene in the movie where out
of nowhere the entire audience screen
and jumped out of their seat and I've
never seen that before
in a theatre that name you see in movie
trailers where someone like throws their
popcorn does that actually happen it
actually happen yeah it wasn't me reason
to see number 2 gory effects
you want to see a movie that's gory this
movie defines gorg I honestly thought we
were watching an unrated version because
there was so much blood I felt him you
feel like you're drunk just feel blood
in male when the movies done just when
you think that it's over and there's no
more putters in your and all that blood
is real
practically oh yeah his uh his makeup
magic and that's why I think it even
looked better because there was so
little CGI like if anything yeah
everything was just this practical blood
in your face and your face and I think
that was way more effective
you know a couple of things that I've
really loved about it was like how
sometimes it was so over the top that it
was actually kind of funny but that felt
like this so means that it adds to the
roller-coaster ride for sure and it's
that rare film where Gore actually makes
sense this is not a torture porn movie
yeah the gore like totally added to the
film and that's where it stayed true to
I think the title of Evil Dead because
it's all about that outrageous gore yeah
that almost makes you laugh because it's
some cooked every everyday movie has
this sort of over-the-topness about it
if you're a gore hound then you probably
won't be disappointed oh absolutely
a woman takes a kitchen knife and cuts
her arm off and they don't do any cheap
camera tricks where they're cutting away
and all I see is blood they show it in
one shot or she's just like slicing up
her oh you think it's gonna be on your
head and you go oh that sucks
no they show you what you're thinking of
it looks like when your arm is really
ripping sometimes you really know well
you show it and it's not as scary as
what's in your head but you know what
half the movie was me going oh yeah it's
gross well it's fun as [ __ ]
reasons just scene number three the
directing and writing okay as far as
like the horror movie genre goes you
know horror movies are very much
underrated but this is just a solid
[ __ ] film in general they went with a
slightly new story because the main
character Mia is going through like a
heroin detox
it's that glue that holds everything
together it makes all the decisions make
sense and all the characters yeah no
one's dumb in this movie
there was no sex no anything they should
link straight to the point and that's
what I like about the writing too they
just didn't rely on stupid it was really
smart cashews a reason to go to this
cabin that's not like what's Aleph RT
the point I was trying to make this yeah
like in the original Evil Dead it gets
to a point early on where you're like
you people should leave by it's pretty
[ __ ] obvious it's time to go but in
this one like everything's just much
more justifiable the characterization is
better the emphasis on the brother and
sister relationship in this made the
film that much more personal one of the
best horror remakes you'll ever see this
and everything is possible like it just
makes sense why they would do certain
things or think surgery even at times
where it seems like a dumb decision when
you break it down psychologically you're
like it actually makes a lot yeah
there's no stupid dad caring right it
was like I've just watched five people
die brutally we shouldn't leave the
house dicks in this movie like no one
who's just the [ __ ] who's like [ __ ]
this you know it's not like a big huge
character study but for what they give
you they certainly give you enough to
latch on to and enough to make the
characters feel like people
it has a lot of style it has a lot of
you know visual panache and the editing
and all that stuff like you could really
feel a strong hand behind the camera and
it's gleeful like even though the movie
is a much more serious dark tone you can
still feel that Glee coming from behind
the camera as they put these people do
these horrible things yeah so so hats
off to fede alvarez you shouldn't have
touched anything from that basement
it takes enough stuff from the original
Evil Dead to be a really great nod and
it keeps the spirit alive while doing
enough of its own thing
not to be a pointless exercise in carbon
copying you no reason to see number four
the cast yes there is one black person
in the cast sort of sort of blithely at
first it's a little questionable she's
in some way yes just put it that way
but she wasn't a stereotype in any way
she was a normal person yeah I liked I
think we're having trouble because there
wasn't one moment where she was like oh
cuz I'm black oh yeah have any attitude
or anything wait what should there a
very solid cast that really knew how to
work together well it's a solid ensemble
for sure there isn't that Bruce Campbell
like standout character but at the same
time I'm kind of glad it works as an
ensemble piece because just the
situation gets too funny yeah cuz you
know what makes the ensemble so great is
you don't really know who's gonna live
by the end of this movie that's such a
good job because some people you're like
oh maybe he's the lead and but the movie
knows how to throw you for a couple of
turns and loops man I loved about that
because when you think somebody's gonna
make it till the end like they just keep
flip-flop and things switch and it's
crazy and you never know they're sort of
playing with your expectation in a way
because it's like oh is anyone gonna
step up and be the new ash like who's it
gonna be
Jane levy in particular I thought she
gave a really good especially the
beginning to when she was going through
a little drug craziness and roll's she's
been she's seeing hallucinations and
everything she was great
she's a stand-up she was great as being
a person with drug addiction and writing
a terrifying [ __ ]
yeah she somehow managed to like she she
went through a mental room
I mean I do have a minor issue with one
character
it was the girlfriend of David she was
the only one that seemed a little tooth
like two-dimensional to me that was the
only character that I didn't quite fully
feel we really got to know but she
doesn't know a bad job no yeah it was
broad enough to that role she actually
did a good job and I care what happened
to her reason to see number 5
cinematography the first 10 minutes of
this film that's like what I was
admiring the most was just how beautiful
everything surprisingly look for Oracle
it's like beautiful to look at and I
like the subtle nods that they had from
the point of view the POV shots yeah oh
yeah the scary yeah they're running in
fact even if you're not a avid film goer
who like looks for stuff like
cinematography I actually think you'll
notice how good this film well there's a
lot of artistic shots in here too just a
lot of everything's beautiful everything
is cut out there's almost poetic
there's really cool framing some really
just sort of nasty stuff there's some
really neat things they do with focus
especially when they're looking through
the book and some of the scenes some of
the gory are like heart-pounding scenes
some of the things they would do with
the camera made those hurt all the much
more like someone gets whacked with
something really hard until lunch in
really quick on it and it's just like
ooh yeah but the way I was shot even
expected horror jumps still get you
reasons to say number six sound design
you gotta get out of those clothes
nobody's gonna piece you're cringing and
squirming already just because of some
of the sound the entire audience like
everybody obviously the ha I see I'm
cringing right now thinking about it
it's like they know one day the the
sound they have is really icky and
sometimes when they take the sound away
it enhanced the experience so right
there's a lot of silent moments that
were really added suspense I mean really
really think about it like out of all
movies where sound really needs to be
effective I think the horror genre is
one of the most important to get the
spook across to get the jumps across you
know sound plays a major part but
usually that's what really gets me the
jump it's not this shot or the action
it's the sound that can like amplifies
the experience great sound reason is see
number seven the music oh yeah let's not
forget the view an air-raid siren man
kind of like this choral sort of it's
kind of like a mix of the original Evil
Dead music and modern day music it's a
great blend of like old fashioned horror
music back then with modern day
let's move on to the reasons not to see
Evil Dead reasons not to see the first
10 minutes of expositional dialogue hey
brother who I haven't seen in a long
time and we are distant because of
something that occurred exactly for me
it didn't bother me that much but I
guess in retrospect thinking about it I
can I can definitely see it like it's
there you know it's kind of ok to me too
because it's like this movies about the
terror ride and you want to get to that
as soon as possible and it was a great
thing about the expositional dialogue is
they at least have character in this
movie so without that character without
that history without that background the
terror wouldn't have been as effective
so you'd need it even though it's kind
of expositional you want to get to the
ride as fast I can see how it we've got
a lot of people though but it definitely
picks up after that point and at the end
of the day I thought they improved upon
the characterization from the original
Evil Dead besides the first ten minutes
of expositional dialogue the characters
are still pretty good
you wanna wrap this up what does
everyone think what's your consensus
Orion's consensus Evil Dead is the
reason horror movies are made Evil Dead
is the reason horror movies are made
this is just a fun gory brutal istic
horror ride Gerry's good senses Evil
Dead is the reason horror remakes are
made Evil Dead is the reason horror
remakes are made remakes are tough
people kind of hate remakes anyway and
this is one of those rare remakes that
really does it right man Alissa's
consensus there are horrifically
enthusiastic reasons to see Evil Dead
there are terrifically enthusiastic
reasons to see Evil Dead I literally
laughed I literally screamed because I
was so horrified I cried it was
embarrassing but that's how effective
this movie is alright movie fans horror
movie lovers if you want to comment
below tell us your reasons to see or not
to see Evil Dead tell us your favorite
part of the movie if you liked it more
than the first one if you liked the
first one better let us know and if you
want to check out my straight to the
point of Evil Dead if you want to know
what the difference is it's straight to
the point very direct go ahead and click
on the link right here and if you want
to see more episodes of reasons to see
click the link right here last but not
least if you want to get updated every
time a new review is out subscribe click
on Alyssa's boobs go ahead and like them
touch them it was gonna cash the site
she wants you to touch them go for it
and there's Evil Dead imagery inside of
her as you can tell good at that Wow
yeah don't even get me started yes the
noise she makes when you clicked her
boobs watched ray
you